14 vendredi consécutif 14 vendredi de
mobilisation pour des milliers de jeunes
schneider du sujet de l'université un
peu partout au québec et dans le monde
en revenons donc sur cette phase prétend
de mobilisation avec toutes ces jeunes
albert lalonde de coporte-parole de pour
un futur montréal ou pour le futur
montréal étudiants secondaire à l'école
joseph françois perrault dans le
quartier saint michel est aussi ashley
torres porte-parole de la planète
s'invite à l'université et du mouvement
pancanadien karim et strike canada
étudiante en sciences politiques à
concordia 14 semaines
grosse couverture médiatique au tout
départ donc ça s'est poursuivi et de la
mobilisation semaine après semaine vous
en retenez quoi d'abord vous acheter
parfois c'était vraiment supporter les
jeunes secondaire être là pour eux
essayé de vraiment être présent le plus
possible ouais c'était lourd s'était
quand même 14 semaines qu'ils ont
vraiment comme pour nous manquer l'école
c'est un peu plus facile que pour un
style ramasse avec l'université en face
aux étudiants du secondaire vous avez
des retenues des trucs nous ont marqué
notre courroux de veron d'émettre des
bruits et mieux ils avaient des
conséquences directes lui à sa fête
je trouve que on était jusque là plus
pour les supporter vraiment il nous
inspirer et nous donner de l'énergie
mais nous on espérait être le pauvre et
en même temps et albert on peut dire
mission accomplie
je pense que oui je pense que dans le
sillon de ce mouvement là il ya
tellement de jeunes qui ont commencé à
parler d'environnement qui ont commencé
à réaliser leur pouvoir leur pouvoir
d'agir la pouvoir d' influence dans la
société
puis a saisi cette influence l'est qui
peuvent avoir à l'utiliser pour le futur
mais est-ce que selon vous ça se
matérialise en ce moment est ce que vous
sentez avoir été écouté par les
gouvernements des actions politiques
est-ce qu'on a eu à c'est à ce moment
qu'on dise tu penses tu donc on a trois
revendications donc aucune les
gouvernements accéder à aucune d'elles
donc si c'est d'abord avoir un programme
national d'éducation relative à
l'environnement qui nous utile pour
lutter contre les changements
climatiques
ensuite le latin de la cedh et de
limitation de la hausse de la
température moyenne mondiale à un point
gray celsius donc défini par les jets
comme étant le seuil pour éviter la
catastrophe
donc là c'est l'atteindre et
troisièmement d'avoir davantage de
transparence dans les investissements
institutionnels aux industries
polluantes
donc aucune de ces trois revendications
qui sont pour nous fondamentale est
conditionnelle à des condition
sinequanone si on veut vous à une
société viable déçu découragé est ce que
ça vous motive davantage qu'est ce qui
se passe à ce point un signe moi je
trouve ça un peu décourageant la fin
parce que en plus de ça ils ont une
question ministériel de poteaux que ton
s'adapter au climat
donc cette cette réponse un examen du
ministère ce soit de français français
pour les son larcin je trouve que ça ça
fait juste ça nous attraper comme vous
êtes sérieux
vous êtes vraiment en train de me
demander si on va s'adapter en place de
nous demander comment on va faire pour
régler ce problème
je trouve que cette réponse nous a un
peu frappé mais ça nous personnellement
ça ne me motive trouve ça nous fait ça
fait qu'aujourd'hui on était trois mille
dans les rues parce que d'habitude si on
est comme deux sens ça nous motive ça
nous motive à la constitution d'environ
20 c'est ça et donc c'est la fin des
classes il y aurait le mois de septembre
est ce qui est des choix stratégiques
qui vont et différence quand on change
la façon finalement de se mobiliser
parce qu'on change le message la façon
de le véhiculer qu'est-ce qui a pour la
suite en septembre prochain
il y en a qui évoque des alliances avec
d'autres générations un peu plus vieille
ça demeure flou c'est certain qu'on veut
entraîner l'ensemble la société civile
avec nous parce qu'au final on milite
pour notre futur mais c'est aussi le
futur de toute la société
si c'est notre avenir collectif c'est la
perpétuation de ce tout ce en quoi on ne
touche toujours cru donc
voilà je pense que c'est inévitable que
tout le monde soit yann est ce qu'une
radicalisation qui est envisagée en ce
moment la désobéissance civile ça fait
partie du cocktail convoi l'échelle
mondiale de d'options pour les
manifestants je crois que c'est
certainement une option mais je crois
que non en ce moment qu'est ce qu'on
veut aussi poussé on est forts au québec
pour la mobilisation mais nous
personnellement on veut établir sa cote
est tout canada on est vraiment à les
exporter nous ne manifestons de toronto
de vancouver et d'halifax pour vraiment
faire sauf un mouvement plus plan canada
est vraiment faire en sorte que on nous
écoute ils ont pas le choix de nous
écouter les élections fédérales s'en
vient de fait on est prêts pour ça c'est
sûr qu'elle ait momentum si on veut des
élections fédérales mais certains ont
peut-être l'impression que c'est un
mouvement de jeunes entre jeunes n'était
pas venu le moment si on veut de pousser
un peu plus le dialogue avec les autres
générations d embarquer dans cette
aventure
qu'en pensez vous bien évidemment on
invite les autres générations à se
joindre à nous puis je puis dire des
activistes est plus jeunes pour le
climat y en avait déjà énormément je
pense qu est la force la jeunesse et
qu'elle apporte un message qui est
différent nous en 2050 quand les
conséquences quand on annonce 250
millions de réfugiés climatiques nom va
être le pour le vivre dans toutes les
catastrophes qui sont annoncés comme
toutes les conséquences des changements
climatiques sont annoncés nous on va les
vivres puis ça a vraiment eu ni
extrêmement direct avec nos vies donc
voilà c'est vrai un message de c'est un
sentiment d'urgence vraiment très
profond et personnels justement cette
semaine le gouvernement fédéral a évoqué
pour la première fois de façon
officielle l'urgence climatique
nationale c'est un gain pour vous cinq
parcelles
je trouve qu'il faut il faut avoir des
actions plus concrètes que j'ai demandé
cette annonce est la leur chance
climatique je pense que il ya beaucoup
de puces façon plus efficace car plus
d'impact que qui pourrait le
gouvernement fédéral a mené à l'appui
pour questionner pour les autres
mouvements plus je trouve que on est en
train de faire comme en ce moment ça
monsieur canadair sont en train de
participer en de grignoter au qu'on est
en train de lancer cet été
donc on est
travailler avec d'autres reconnaissent
aussi et avoir notre place nous les
jeunes mais c'est vraiment choqué il
faut vraiment que nous mobilisons jane
le plus possible pour après avoir cette
commune balance avec les adultes pour
amener un effet d'entraînement si le but
recherché pour vous ben merci beaucoup
bons examens finaux bon été et on verra
donc en septembre
quelle forme ça va prendre tout ça merci
encore merci au revoir